you work incessantly you you try all
kinds of different mediums you do a
stage show with Steve Martin I do Steve
Martin you got you and Steve Martin
travel around and give it a cut it's
called an evening you'll forget for the
rest of your life
but you know it's an incredible show you
too sparking live right up there on the
stage must be a joy to work with Steve
Martin listen I've known him well since
three migos I'd never met him until
three amigos and then we became great
great friends and this is so much fun
yeah we we do see the things about Steve
people wonder what he's like and it's
very much interesting enough like the
movie deliverance it's all fun and games
until the banjos come up I was a Steve I
said Steve what would you be doing if
you weren't a legendary comedic actor
and he said probably what you're doing
you know that white haired bastard it is
uh but you guys you're on the road
constantly together you must you've
gotten to know him just about probably
better than most any friend you have uh
I think so I think I mean I think that
it's it's I think that we have a very
easy easy time very easy chemistry you
know we insult each other continually
yeah throughout without the evening and
no one seems to but it never goes over
line so I guess that's a good act of
friendship I say at one point he is so
pale he looks like someone put it to pay
on a urinal
I always love what you say about me I'm
Eve I don't even think you said in the
show but whenever like several years ago
I saw you you said to me Conan whatever
work you're having done like plastic
surgery I'd say do 30% more and then
stop you're amazing I can't afford work
what would i I went to youtube to see my
last appearance here you know just cuz
that's what I do cuz I'm right needy yes
sure sure and but it's hilarious reading
the comments down below cuz I came out
and insulted you yeah as I often do and
but the comments below are hilarious
like oh my god like Conan could so put
him away if you wanted to and then the
next comment is it makes you sound like
a sandwich yeah let it out it dude I'm
sure they're good friends so you're
probably stupid yourself it's it is
amazing whenever I mean we've known each
other a long time you're one of my
all-time comedy heroes and you come out
you do these terrific jokes that's why I
don't read comments on the internet
because I've told you like I have you do
a joke but you have though you've been
you tell you can't tell me you've been
up to in the morning in the bad boxers
and the kind of training bra whatever
you wear with the so far you know far
you're right
oh come on you again
yes I do that a lousy I do that you told
me by the scroll down hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos please